we're going to begin with the news of a
possible indictment against former
president Donald Trump over the weekend
the former president claimed he will be
arrested tomorrow although there is no
evidence that that is going to happen
and no official has said that that is
true now he's facing criticism for
calling on his supporters to protest
raising concerns that his words could
lead to violence that are very similar
to what happened on January 6. we all
remember that day Robert Costa is
outside Manhattan Criminal Court Bob
good morning to you and we understand
that there may be additional testimony
today
good morning Gail that's correct the CBS
News has learned that the grand jury may
hear today from an additional witness
Bob Costello a former legal adviser to
Michael Cohen a key witness in this
investigation we're told that Mr
Costello might question The credibility
of Mr Cohen and this all comes after The
Fallout over the weekend from former
president Trump's comments
this is selective prosecution if I were
president Trump I take this all the way
to the damn Supreme Court former
president Donald Trump and his allies on
the political and legal Warpath over the
weekend as Trump faces down a possible
indictment in Manhattan Criminal Court
on Saturday Trump claimed he will be
arrested on Tuesday of next week and
urged his supporters to protest and take
our nation back he then urged in a
follow-up we must save America protest
protest protest
CBS News has learned that some Trump
allies privately debated over his call
for protests
[Music]
it has Echoes of Trump's call for
protests on January 6 2021 the day the
capital was attacked in response to
Trump's posts Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg told colleagues in
an email that safety is the top priority
and we do not tolerate attempts to
intimidate our office or threaten the
rule of law in New York Trump's
potential 2024 Rivals are also reacting
former vice president Mike Pence spoke
out against any possible indictment in
this case just feels like a politically
charged prosecution here and even some
Republican critics of trump say it could
play to his political Advantage a lot of
the Democrats have misplayed this in
terms of building Sympathy for the
former president the Manhattan district
attorney is investigating alleged hush
money payments made to adult film star
Stormy Daniels on Trump's behalf by his
former attorney Michael Cohen at a
crucial moment in the 2016 campaign
Trump denies any wrongdoing but Cohen's
lawyer Lanny Davis CBS News his client
testified truthfully to the grand jury
earlier this month and now it is in
their hands if there was any political
motivation to prevent the alleged affair
with Stormy Daniels from coming out
right before the election and a jury is
to conclude that there is any political
motivation then I think that's the key
issue
Trump's lawyer Joe takapina tells CBS
news that if charged the Trump legal
team will be very aggressive in
combating the indictment and questioning
its credibility and scope they will also
question The credibility of Michael
Cohen who was once charged with lying to
Congress Michael Cohen though will be
here in New York today as a possible
rebuttal witness before the grand jury
Gail
all right Bob thank you thank you very
much